bachelor contestant rachel kirkenl took
to instagram on thursday to address
allegations of racism leveled against
her
kirkunel has been an early front-runner
since matt james's season of the
bachelor premiered
last month i know i'm just speaking for
myself here but like i just feel like
there's
some connection without you see me
locking eyes with you at these
yeah however shortly after the season
premiere a tick tock user accused
kerkinell of bullying her
in the past for dating black men last
week another user accused her of liking
racist photos
and pics have surfaced of curcanel at an
old south plantation themed party while
in college in 2018.
while there have been rumors circulating
there have also been truths that have
come to light that i need to address
i hear you and i'm here to say i was
wrong
kirkenel apologized to the communities
and individuals that she's harmed
writing that she's ashamed of her lack
of education
and adding it is no one's responsibility
to educate me
i am learning and will continue to learn
how to be anti-racist
the picture was from 2018
at an old south antebellum party so i
think
you know when you hold that one
kirkenel's statement comes one day after
bachelor host chris harrison
issued an apology for quote wrongly
speaking in a manner that perpetuates
racism when he defended her in an
interview with former bachelorette
rachel lindsay
well rachel is it a good look in 2018 or
is it not a good look in 2021
because there's a big deal ever cause
you're she's celebrating the old
south she's so if i went to that party
what would i represent at that party
bachelor nation stars were quick to
weigh in on harrison's interview
mike johnson wrote on instagram
accountability is tough love
but love nonetheless jubilee sharp
tweeted that she wasn't shocked by the
interview
while nick viall called harrison's
comments disappointing and
harmful i am
extremely
disappointed um in chris another former
bachelorette caitlyn bristow
also opened up about it on instagram
live thursday
i think he for sure needs to do more
than put out a statement
i am really really disappointed um
i stand with rachel
lindsey also speaking out the current
contestants on
matt james's season who shared a united
message on thursday
denouncing the comments made by harrison
lindsay saw the group's statement
reposted it and added that she's moved
by their support
and on friday here's what lindsay had to
say while speaking with good morning
america
you have the face the spokesperson
of that franchise say the things that
were said this week
and it lets you know the work isn't done
so
i am now going to hold her accountable
for the things that she said in her
statement
and i expect to see her act on them
words
are only part of it we need to see what
those actions are
you